let's continue with our orange juice
producing example and in this situation
i want to think about what a what a
rational quantity of orange juice might
be or what what would be a rational
quantity of orange juice to produce
given a market price so let's say that
the market price right now the market
price of orange juice is 50 cents a
gallon
and i'm going to assume that there are
many producers here so we're going to
have to be price takers obviously we
want to charge as much as we can per
gallon but if we charge any if we charge
even a penny over 50 cents a gallon then
people are going to buy all of their
orange juice from other people so we
this is the price that we can charge 50
cents per gallon so if we think about it
in terms of marginal revenue revenue per
incremental gallon well that first
incremental gallon we're going to get 50
cents that next incremental gallon we're
going to get 50 cents for that one and
the next one we're going to get 50 cents
as well for the first thousand gallons
we're gonna get 50 cents for each of
those gallons for the first 10 000
gallons we'll get 50 cents per gallon so
our marginal revenue curve looks
something like this
our marginal revenue is a flat curve
right at 50 cents a gallon so that is
our marginal revenue at at 50 cents
at a market price of 50 cents per gallon
now in this situation what's a
reasonable quantity that we would want
to produce and there's two dynamics here
we want to produce as much as possible
as much
as possible so that we can so that we
can spread our fixed costs over those
gallons spread
our
fixed cost is one way of thinking about
fixed costs or another way of thinking
about it is
we have a certain amount of fixed costs
we are spending one thousand dollars no
matter what so why don't we try to get
as much revenue as possible to try to
make up for those fixed costs or if we
think about it in terms of average fixed
cost the more quantity that we produce
the at the component of the cost for
that from the fixed costs go down and
down and down so we want to have as much
as possible to spread our fixed costs
now the one thing that we do need to
think about is especially once we kind
of get beyond the beyond this little dip
in the marginal cost curve and as we're
producing more and more units the
marginal cost is going up higher and
higher and higher we don't want to
produce so much that the cost of
producing that incremental unit the
marginal cost of that incremental unit
is more than the marginal cost of that
actual or the marginal cost of that
incremental unit is not higher than the
marginal revenue that we're getting on
that incremental unit so until
until
until
marginal revenue is equal to marginal
cost or another way of thinking about it
you don't want
you don't want
marginal cost and this is after we go
through this little dip here we're
trying to do as much as possible
marginal cost is going higher and higher
higher we don't want to produce this
much right over here because here our
our that cost for that extra gallon is
higher than what we're going to get for
that extra gallon looks like that cost
for that extra gallon might be 53 cents
while we're only going to get 50 cents
for that extra gallon so every extra
gallon we produce over here we're going
to be losing money so you don't want you
don't want marginal cost to be greater
than marginal revenue
marginal revenue
so when you look at the curves like this
it makes sense to just say well when
does marginal revenue equal marginal
cost and that's this point right over
here and that is the rational amount to
produce so that is 9000 units so we're
going to be at this line right over here
we're going to produce 9000 gallons of
juice
our revenue that we're going to get is
going to be the area is going to be the
rectangle of the area that's as high as
our that's as high as the price we're
getting per unit times the number of
units so this is going to be the total
revenue we get if we were to shade this
in and i'm not going to shade it in
because it's going to make my whole
diagram messy and what is our total cost
well we have our average total cost
right here this is our average total
cost are 48 cents that's this little
green triangle right over here so it's
48 cents per unit times the total number
of units our costs are the area under
the area in this rectangle so if i were
to shade this in this little slightly
smaller rectangle and so our profits are
the difference between the two our total
revenue is the area under the
the rectangle that has this
the marginal revenue line is this upper
bound and our cost is a rectangle that
has our average total cost this line
right over here as its upper bound so
our profits our profits in this
circumstance are going to be the area
right over here the height is the
difference between our marginal cost
which is the same as our marginal
revenue and our total cost so it's going
to be the height is going to be these
two cents right over here we're taking
the difference between 50 and 48 so it's
going to be 2 cents and then the
quantity produced is going to be 9 000
units so 9 000 we're making 2 cents per
unit are to remember we're
our average cost our average total cost
is 48 cents per unit we're selling them
at 50 cents per unit so we're making two
cents per unit i wrote 20. we're making
2 cents per unit 2 cents times 9 000
units times 9 000 units gives us was
that that's 18 000 cents or 180 dollars
of
profit
now what i want you to think about and
we'll answer this in the next video is
does it make sense
does it make sense to sell units at all
and if so how many should we sell if and
here's the question if the market price
if the market price is lower than your
average total cost so does it make sense
and how many units does it make us does
it make sense to produce let's say if
the market price let's say if the market
price were 45 cents 45 cents per unit
does it make sense for us to produce